remember Zoltar the fortune teller from
the movie big mysterious machine turned
a young boys wish into reality in real
life there are hundreds of Zolt ours all
over the country you can trace them all
back to this guy my name is Olaf Stanton
and I make soltahr all the friends
characters in limited a company that
makes animated talking characters and
one of those machines is the fortune
teller the fortune teller is probably
the one of the oldest games there is
it's been around since the turn of the
century perhaps the most famous one is
Zoltar but just to be clear they didn't
make the one from the movie big the
Zoltar in the movie big was basically a
movie prop it was never made to be a
manufactured game our Zoltar has the
talking and eye movement and
head-turning
and spits out a card at the end of the
conversation and gives you some good
words of advice every soul time machine
it's custom made the first thing we do
is get the cabinet started then we'll
cast a head out of our latex material we
put the eyeballs in we paint the head
then it goes to our wig department
Zoltar x' goatee is put on the teeth
that put in which are actually my teeth
wait do your teeth yes they're actually
my teeth I actually made a mold on my
teeth so every Zoltar you see out there
has my teeth you know and then we put
all the components in that make the card
come out and make a talk and give the
different messages and then Zoltar is
ready to go
although Zoltar is the star for a
fortune teller line he's not the only
fortune teller that we make we have
pappy we have the old pirate in those
fortunes
that's all left - we try to make all of
our fortunes on the lighter side good
words of wisdom and advice I think one
of my favorite is sometimes it's better
to say too little than to say too much
and regret it later there's a lot of
good words of wisdom that come out of
soltahr I think people just like to see
something that they can relate to and
say oh yeah how did you know that that's
so cool it really does bring out the
child in all of us to see your fortune
on our card
well unless of course you're talking
about Tom Hanks in the movie big because
he gets well you know big
[Music]